السلام عليكم. سلام عليكم.
لقد تم طردنا من الجنة. هكذا
اعلنها الاوروبيون والسبب روسيا
موسكو تكشف تورط واشنطن في تفجير
انابيب الغاز وتطالب بقمة طارئة
لحلف الناتو. اوروبا تعاقب دولة
عربية بسبب دعمها لروسيا.
وبريطانيا تضع خطة للحرب
الاوكرانية والجيش الخفي لبوتين
يخترق موقع حلف شمال الاطلسي
مخازن اسلحة الغرب وتحذيرات
روسية. هولندا هي التالية بعد
اوكرانيا. الولايات المتحدة تغلق
مجالها الجوي وبكين تكسر صمتها
لتحرك واشنطن قواتها الضاربة في
بحر الصين الجنوبي. واما جارتها
اليابان ها هي تنشر اسلحتها في
حدود روسيا ليأتيها الرد سريعا
من بوتين. وفي تركيا وسوريا
رائحة الموت تنتشر وعداد الموتى
لا ومواقف الضحايا تجعل القلب
يقطر دما. روسيا توسع اهدافها
باتجاه الناتو. مع مضي الايام
الحرب الاوكرانية تتعقد اكثر
فاكثر والاوضاع تسوء بشكل لا
يصدق لتعلنها اوروبا بصوت عال.
لقد اصبحنا في الجحيم. نعم لقد
قالها وزير الخارجية النمساوي
الكسندر شالنبيرغ بان بدء
العملية الروسية العسكرية في
اوكرانيا يعتبر بمثابة طرد
الاوروبيين الجنة. هنا تبدأ
البوصلة الروسية بتغيير مسارها
لتنحرف نحو بولندا. ولكن لماذا؟
الاجابة بسيطة. حيث صرح رئيس
الوزراء البولندي ماتيوس
مورافيتسكي بان بلاده نقلت
مائتين وخمسين دبابة من طراز تي
سفنتي تو الى اوكرانيا، وسترسل
في القريب العاجل ستين دبابة
اضافية من طراز تي سفنتي تو وبي
تي ناينتي وان وتو ورد واربع
عشرة دبابة ليوفرت الى
الاوكرانيين. اليكم المصدر. وفي
غضون ذلك ذكرت وسائل اعلام
بولندية ان وارسو سلمت كييف
مائتي دبابة من طراز تي اثنان
وسبعين اضافة الى عشرات العربات
المدرعة. اعلنت الخارجية الروسية
ان موسكو سترد على الفور على اي
تهديد لمناطق الشرق الاقصى
الروسي. وفيها نشر اليابان
لصواريخ فرض صوتية قرب الحدود
الروسية. ليأتي الرد الروسي على
لسان سيناتوراه عن جمهورية القرم
الروسية اولجا كوفيديدي والتي
قالت ان الولايات المتحدة تستخدم
بولندا كورقة مساومة وستصبح
البديل الاوكراني في الحلقة
المناهضة لروسيا. لكن المساعدات
قد لا بعد اليوم. حيث صرح وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق مارك
اسبر بان الاوان قد فات على
تسليم اوكرانيا انظمة باتريوت
للدفاع الجوي. فاوكرانيا كانت
بحاجة اليها قبل عدة اشهر بحسب
تعبيره. وماذا عن الدبابات هذا?
ليجيب امين عام حلف الناتوين
ستولتنبرغ. ان عليهم ضمان ان
يكون لكييف جيشا بعد اي اتفاق
سلام. فهل حان وقت السلام? ام ان
الناتو قد نفذت؟ يعود ستولتنبرج
ويجيب قائلا ان الحلف مستعد
للانخراط في اي جهود دولية لبحث
الضمانات الامنية لاوكرانيا. اي
انه مقتنع بالتفاوض مع موسكو.
خلصت الحدوتة كما يقولها
السوريون. هنا ستولتنبرج يواصل
حديثه مؤكدا ان امدادات الاسلحة
الكبيرة التي قدمها حلف الناتو
لاوكرانيا استنزفت مخزونات من
الذخائر لان استهلاك اوكرانيا
للذخائر يفوق وتيرة انتاج الحلف
لها بعدة اضعاف حسب قوله. وهو ما
سيتطلب عامين ونصف بدلا من عام
واحد كما كان عليه الحال في
السابق. فياله من وضع صعب لاقوى
حلف عسكري في العالم. ومن مخازن
الناتو الى مصانع الاسلحة
البريطانية. وبعدما فتح رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني رويشيسوناك
الباب امام لارسال طائرات مقاتلة
الى اوكرانيا. ها هي لندن تخطط
لخطوة اخرى قد تجرهم نحو مواجهة
مباشرة مع موسكو وذلك باستعداد
البريطانيين لاقامة مشاريع
مشتركة مع كييف لتصنيع الاسلحة
والمركبات محليا بموجب ترخيص.
وذلك بحسب مجلة التليجراف. فيما
اعلن السفير الروسي في بريطانيا
اندري كلين ان بريطانيا تخطط
لمصادرة الاصول المجمدة وتعد
تشريعا لذلك وفقا لوكالة
نوفوستي. لينتقل الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى العقوبات كرد على
الروس. لكن هذه المرة تم فرض
عقوبات ضد شركة شحن اماراتية
كجزء من حزمة العقوبات العاشرة
ضد روسيا. وذلك بزعم تحايلها على
العقوبات المفروضة ضد موسكو وفق
صحيفة بوليتكو. ومن معارك
العقوبات الى حرب الاستخبارات.
وبعد ان نشر صحفي امريكي عن تورط
واشنطن بزرع متفجرات بخطوط
انابيب الغاز بحسب روترز خرجت
المتحدثة الروسية ماريا زخاروفا
وهي الخالة فرنسا فرع روسيا وذلك
بسبب تصريحاتها اللاذعة لنطلق
عليها هذه التسمية. فهي تعلن ان
هناك حقائق كثيرة تتوفر بشأن
وطالبت بعقد قمة طارئة لحلف شمال
الاطلسي لبحث فهل يستجيب الحلف
لطلبها؟ هنا يظهر جيش بوتين
الخفي وينفذ هجومه على حلف
الناتو حيث اعلن هاكرز روس من
مجموعة كلنت انهم اخترقوا الموقع
الالكتروني لقيادة حلف الناتو
الجوية في قاعدة رينشتاين
العسكرية الامريكية في المانيا
الى حرب اخرى وخصم اخر. حيث صرح
نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي اندري
رودينكو بان روسيا ردوا فورا في
حال نشر اليابان صواريخ فرط
صوتية على الجزر اليابانية
بالقرب من الحدود الروسية.
اندلاع حرب البالونات. ازمة
المناطيد تتشعب والولايات
المتحدة تدخل حربا مجهولة ستكون
الصين احد اطرافها. لكن واشنطن
لا تعلم من هم الاعداء الاخرون.
لتعلن امريكا اغلاق المجال الجوي
فوق ولاية بعد رصد جسم مجهول في
السماء قبل ان يتبين ان خللا في
الرادار تسبب في الاغلاق بينما
كانت قيادة الدفاع الجوي لامريكا
الشمالية اكدت ان طائرات مقاتلة
امريكية قد اسقطت جسما غير معروف
فوق بحيرة هولن على الحدود مع
كندا بعد اسقاط جسم اخر فوق
الاسكا. ليصبح بذلك رابع جسم
مجهول يتم اسقاطه. فهل هناك عدو
اخر الامريكان غير الصين الغموض
يكتنف هذه الاجسام الطائرة. وهنا
تعلن بكين ان جسما طائرا مجهول
الهوية شوهد قبالة سواحل مقاطعة
شامبو بشرق الصين وكان من الممكن
ان تسقطه السلطات المختصة وفق
صحيفة جلوبال تايمز الصينية. هنا
حرب البالونات تشتعل. لتكسر بكين
صمتها وتعلن وزارة خارجيتها انه
منذ العام الماضي علقت بالونات
الارتفاع في الولايات المتحدة
فوق الفضاء الجوي الصيني دون اذن
من الصين احدى عشرة مرة وفقا
لوكالة رويترز توتر البلدان على
اثر قضية المنطاد وتم تعليق
زيارة وزير الخارجية الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن لبكين. ليطفي
الامريكان النار بالوقود حيث
ظهرت مجموعة القوة الضاربة
لحاملة الطائرات يو اس اس نيمز
والوحدة الاستكشافية البحرية
عشرة تقومان بعمليات استكشافية
متكاملة في بحر الصين الجنوبي في
تحركات اشعلت النار في صدور
الصينيين اذا فكيف سترد بكين.
رائحة الموت تعانق السماء. ما
اقسى هذه اللحظات. يمر الوقت
ثقيلا كالجبال على متضرري
الزلزال. ورائحة الموت تنتشر في
كل مكان داخل الركام تحت
الانقاض. عدد ضحايا الزلزال
يرتفع الى ستة وثلاثين الف قتيل
في سوريا وتركيا. وبينما تمنح
المانيا تأشيرة خاصة للمتضررين
من السوريين والاتراك ها هو منسق
الامم المتحدة للمساعدات
الانسانية يعترف بان المنظمة
خذلت سكان سوريا بعد الزلزال
المدمر مؤكدا على التزام المنظمة
بتصحيح الاخفاقات في المنطقة. ها
بعد اسبوع ما اقبح المتشدقين
بالانسانية. هنا يواصل الزلزال
رعبه بهزتين ارضيتين جعلتا فرق
الانقاذ توقف عملها لساعات في
تركيا. لكن هذا الشاب التركي
الذي يبكي بحرقة لا يزال قلبه
معلقا بالامل بعد ثمانية ايام.
حيث ينتظر عروسه العالقة تحت
الانقاض ويحمل قميصها. قلوبنا
الصغيرة لا تتحمل يا صديقي. وهذا
الطفل السوري تطوع ليكون مترجما
لتسهيل عمل فرق الانقاذ السعودية
والتركية وذلك اضعف الايمان.
وهنا رجل مسن ينصب خيمته قرب
بيته المهدم. رافضا ودعا عائلته
التي غمرها الركام. ما اصعب
مواقف الفراق يا ابتي. اما في
اغرب مواقف الزلزال. هذا الشيخ
تفاجأ بعودة ابنائه بعد ان كان
قد حفر قبور بيديه عن اي مشاعر
جياشة نتحدث لتعلن قطر تبرعها
لسوريا وتركيا بعشرة الاف مقصورة
استخدمت في كأس العالم لتصبح
مأوى للمتضررين. الاحداث
والتطورات. طائرات حربية تابعة
للكيان الاسرائيلي تقصف مواقع
متعددة في قطاع غزة محدثة دمارا
هائلا في الممتلكات دون وقوع
اصابات. بينما تصد الشرطة
الاسرائيلية المتظاهرين ضد
نتنياهو في تل ابيب. الرئيس
المصري نرفض الاجراءات
الاسرائيلية في القدس وادعو
المجتمع الدولي لانقاذ حل
الدولتين. يا سيدي الرئيس لماذا
لا نقف مع فلسطين كما وقف الغرب
مع اوكرانيا وروسيا تحدد وجهتها
القادمة بعد اوكرانيا وبين الصين
والولايات المتحدة حرب البناطيل
الطائرة ترعب الدولتين.